[Music]
we all know what our favorite cartoon
characters sound like but have you ever
stopped to wonder about the voice behind
the character we have and we're talking
about that today be sure to stay to the
end to see how a youtuber brought new
life to a classic franchise if this is
your first time visiting the things then
do us a favor hit the subscribe button
and give this video a thumbs up today we
are going to tell you about the voices
behind your favorite cartoons Mel Blanc
the voice of Warner Brothers when we
think of our favorite cartoon characters
we think of the wide variety of voices
that they have but one of the greatest
cartoon voiceover artists of all time
was someone who we could probably do a
video about and just focus on him one of
the most iconic animation studios ever
is Warner Brothers when you think of
them you think of such classic
characters as Bugs Bunny Daffy Duck
Porky Pig Yosemite Sam Sylvester the cat
Tweety pie and so many others from the
Golden Age of American animation but
what is really remarkable
is that they were all voiced by one
person Mel Blanc mr. blank was the first
superstar voice in cartoons and he was
the first voice actor to receive a
credit on his shorts that have
entertained generations of people across
the world in his autobiography he said
that he got his name on screen because
the studio would not give him a pay
raise although later research has cast
doubt on that but regardless Mel Blanc
was an incredibly talented voice-over
artist and he is someone who pretty much
defined what could be done he passed
away in 1989 at the age of 81 but
there's one more incredible fact about
him that we wanted to share on his
tombstone there's his name his nickname
the man of a thousand voices and rather
wonderfully that's all folks
gray Griffin de Lisle Lola Lana Lily
loud and others if an animated series
has a lot of characters in it there is a
pretty good chance that one person will
do more than one character and there's a
good chance that the particular actor
will have voiced other characters and
other programs to a show that we love
that has a lot of different characters
is of course the loud house but we're
you aware that the voices of lana lily
and lola loud were all done by the same
person that's right they were all voiced
by american
actress great Griffin who was previously
known as fraida Lyle gray is a very
talented voice actress and she has been
in great demands throughout her career
so the chances are that you won't just
have heard her in the loud house she's
been in a lot of other great shows for
instance have you seen scooby-doo
mystery Incorporated well if you have
then you might potentially recognize her
as the voice of Daphne or if you've been
watching Captain Underpants
the first epic movie then she's in that
too you know miss Edith and throw the
grumpy school secretary that's her voice
too
that's not to mention the countless
videogame characters that she is voiced
she has also appeared in live-action TV
once playing a teacher in an episode of
That 70's Show dan Castellaneta Homer
Simpson the single most successful
animated TV show probably of all time is
the Simpsons ever since it came on to
our screens in late 1989 the stories of
the average American family from the
town of Springfield has been a popular
culture touchstone and perhaps the
single most iconic character in the show
is Homer Simpson in case you haven't
seen the Simpsons although we suspect
you will have done that's how big the
program is Homer is a good-hearted
although rather sluggish and lazy father
of the Simpson family by the way if you
ever wondered how Homer Simpson got his
name the show's creator Matt Groening
father was called Homer but anyway he
has a very distinctive and much imitated
voice courtesy of after dan Castellaneta
he voiced Homer in more than 20 seasons
of The Simpsons appearing in every
episode but it isn't just Homer that he
does the voice for he has also been the
voice of grandpa Simpson Barney Gumbel
Krusty the Klown groundskeeper Willie
mayor Quimby Hans Moleman sideshow Mel
and more on The Simpsons that's not to
mention his successful career as a
stand-up comic and a recording artist
too and if you ever wanted to see him do
live-action work he's appeared in
friends that 70 show and Desperate
Housewives oh and unlike the character
he's most famous for voicing he is a
vegetarian teetotal excercise fans
Lorenzo music Garfield and Peter Venkman
if you grew up in the 1980s or the 1990s
there are some cartoon shows that were
pretty much essential viewing one of
those shows was Garfield and friends
based on the
classic newspaper cartoons by Jim Davis
this show was a massive hit among
children and adults worldwide and a bit
factor in the success of the show was
the voice of Garfield if you had been a
fan of the comic strip then the way
Garfield sounded on TV was pretty much
the same as how it sounded in your head
it was lazy trolley and pretty much
perfect and the man behind the voice was
Lorenzo music a New York City born and
Minnesota raised voice actor he had
previously found some level of success
as the voice of Carlton the doorman a
character who was heard but never seen
in the CBS sitcom Rhoda but this took
his career to a whole new level he was
able to combine being the voice of Jon
Arbuckle's cat with a range of other
roles perhaps the most notable among
those was that of Peter Venkman in the
Real Ghostbusters although ville-marie
had made the role his own on the big
screen for some of us Peter will always
sound a bit like Garfield but here's a
cool fact after Lorenzo music passed
away in 2001 the voice of Garfield was
taken over by Bill Murray
Tom Kinney is spongebob squarepants when
you think about the most successful kids
cartoon shows of the 21st century
there's one name that comes up perhaps
more often than any other program that
name is SpongeBob SquarePants this show
about the short-order cook who lives in
bikini bottom with his friend Patrick
has won the hearts of millions of
viewers worldwide he lives in a
pineapple under the sea and do we love
him but spongebob wouldn't be spongebob
if it wasn't for the way that he sounds
there's a certain genius in the way that
the character can sound smart and funny
and sweet and lovable all at the same
time so we have to take our collective
hats off to the vocal genius behind
spongebob and that's a man called Tom
Kinney like a lot of voice actors he
started his career as a stand-up
comedian working with a cult hero Bobcat
Goldthwait's
he had quite a successful career but it
was when he took the job in SpongeBob
SquarePants that he really became a star
he also appeared in such shows as
Dilbert and Adventure Time and he also
used his voice in the Transformers
movies franchise if you're wondering how
he got the voice for spongebob he says
he wanted it to be halfway between a
child and an adult sort of like a
character someone likes
and Laurel or Jerry Lewis would play
Zach Allison aka Steven universe and
recent here is a TV show that has become
a massive hit among fans of cartoons has
been Steven universe if you haven't ever
seen the program well you should because
it's really really good
it's about a boy called Steven who lives
in a Beach City with his friends pearl
garnet and amethyst pearl garnet and
amethyst are actually aliens called the
crystal gems and Steven works with them
to protect the world from their fellow
extraterrestrials
what is quite notable about the show is
that it was the first animated series on
the Cartoon Network to be developed and
created entirely by a woman Rebecca
sugar Rebecca also based the character
of Steven on her younger brother who was
also called Steven but the title
character is who we are going to talk
about and his voice is provided by a
young actor called Zach Allison Zach's a
talented person and he's been appearing
in things since he was seven one of his
earliest appearances was one of the kids
on the quiz show are you smarter than a
5th grader and he has also lent his
voice to Prince James in Sofia the first
but it's not just acting that he excels
in know he is also a talented piano
player and he has made some recordings
for his website the two voices of
Lincoln loud something that you may just
have noticed if you watch a cartoon over
a long period of time is that sometimes
the cast changes even if the characters
do not that's one of the advantages of
being an animation we guess your
characters can keep looking the same
even if the way they sound changes a
little bit
that means shows can in theory at least
keep going for longer let's put it
another way
have you known a live-action to show
where they change a character's actor
and that works we can think of one apart
from Doctor Who and that doesn't really
count that said if there is one don't be
shy to tell us in the comments anyway
this has happened in one of our favorite
cartoons which is the loud house this
programs main character is Lincoln loud
who is a 10 year old boy now what you
may not have noticed is that Lincoln's
voice changed between the first and
second series that is because the actor
who voiced him in the first series grant
Palmer got older and as he got older his
voice got deeper so he had to be
replaced by Colin Dean
second series however those of you who
have sharper ears might have recognized
the voice of a bourbon burger employee
that's because it was grant Palmer
making a return in a cameo role the
genius of Harry Shearer something you
discover when you look into the voice
actors behind some of our favorite
cartoon characters is how many of them
had a background in stand-up comedy they
quite often they made their name as a
voice actor rather than as a comedian
sometimes though the opposite is true
and the comedian is successful even if
the show they provide the voice for
isn't but there is one exception someone
who is a legend of voice acting and a
legend of comedy - that person is Harry
Shearer if you have ever watched the
Simpsons then the chances are that
you've heard him let's put it this way
there are some classic Simpsons scenes
which involve mr. burns talking to his
assistant Waylon Smithers when those
scenes were recorded there was just one
person in the vocal booth and that was
Harry Shearer he has also done the
voices of Principal Skinner Ned Flanders
Reverend Lovejoy Kent Brockman dr.
Hibbert and others but it's not just the
Simpsons he's been on he has been a cast
member of Saturday Night Live and he's
appeared in such films as Godzilla The
Truman Show and Wayne's World 2 but for
a lot of people the role he will be
remembered as is that of Derek smalls in
this is spinal tap Harry Shearer is one
of those people who is genuinely
brilliant justin roiland both rick and
morty one of the smash hits of the
cartoon world in the 2010 has been Rick
and Morty this program is about a crazy
scientist Rick Sanchez and his foot upon
grandson Morty Smith and it combines
interstellar science fiction with
domestic humour to say it has been a hit
has been a little bit of an
understatement since it debuted on the
Cartoon Network's Adult Swim offshoot in
2013 the show has got itself a dedicated
hardcore fan base as well as the weird
and off-kilter humor that the show
relies on the characterization has been
something that has drawn people in and a
big part of that is the voice acting
however what you may not have realized
is that both Rick and Morty are voiced
by the same person that is the show's
co-creator Justin roiland he came up
with the concept behind the show with
Dan
Harmon and ended up putting his voice on
the two main characters however as well
as writing producing and voicing Rick
and Morty Justin has also appeared in a
wide range of other things for instance
he has written for the cult sci-fi
comedy show Mystery Science Theater 3000
the return he appeared with comedy
rockers Tenacious D on a short film and
he has hosted podcasts and then on video
games however we're sure he'll forgive
us if we say that for us he'll always be
both Rick and Morty Wendy the Powerpuff
Girl sometimes programs that were big
for one particular generation of people
get remade and then they get a whole new
group of fans one of the great kids
cartoon series that that has happened to
is the Powerpuff Girls free kids growing
up around the turn at the Millennium the
stories of Blossom Bubbles and Buttercup
were thrilling and iconic when the
Cartoon Network announced it was
rebooting the show in 2016 lots of us
were really excited
however our enthusiasm for that was
tempered by not knowing how people who
weren't around when the show was first
on would take it luckily the newer
generation really got into that now a
big big part of that was the new
Powerpuff Girl Bullis bliss or to give
her full name bliss Tina Consuela
utonium was voiced by Wendy h now you
might not know that name but if we told
you that she was better known as windy
then we think you might win g is a video
blogger whose videos on makeup tips have
seen her get more than 9 million
subscribers as of December 2017 we think
there's a good chance that you'll
recognize her so her voice was something
that ended up making the show successful
but we wondered what other youtubers
could do a good job in voice acting and
have there been any great voice
performances that we've left off let us
know in the comments and that's all for
the voices behind your favorite cartoons
if you liked it then you should check
out ten cartoon secrets finally revealed
thanks for watching and don't forget to
subscribe
[Music]